what I want to do in this video is
explore the types of two-dimensional
shapes we can construct by taking planar
slices of cubes so what am I talking
about
well let's say we wanted to construct a
square how could we slice a cube with a
plane to get a the intersection of this
cube and that plane to be a square well
imagine if that plane were to cut just
like this a square is maybe the most
obvious one so it cuts the top right
over there it cuts the top right over
there it cuts this side right over here
cuts this side right over here it cuts
the side I guess in the back if it's a
glass cube you'd be able to see it right
over there dotted line and then it cuts
this right over here so you could
imagine you could imagine a plane that
did this and if I wanted to draw the
broader plane I could draw it like this
let me see if I can do a decent an
adequate job of drawing the actual I
guess you could say part of the plane
that is cutting this cube that is
cutting this cube it would look it could
look something it could look something
like this and I can even color in the
part of the plane that you could
actually that you could actually see if
the cube were if the cube were opaque if
it were if you couldn't see through it
and actually but if you could see it
through it you see this dotted line and
the plane would look like that so a
square is pretty is a pretty
straightforward thing to get if you're
doing a planar slice of a cube but what
about a rectangle how can you get that
and at any point I encourage you pause
the video and try to think about it on
your own how can you get these shapes
that I'm talking about well a rectangle
you can actually cut like this so if you
cut this side like this and then cut
that side like that and then you cut
this side like that I think you see
where this going this side like that and
then you cut the bottom right over there
then the intersection of your the plane
that you're cutting with so the
intersection let's see this could be the
plane that I'm actually cutting with so
the intersection of the plane that I'm
cutting with and my cube
is going to be is going to be a
rectangle so it might look like this and
once again let me shade in the stuff if
you kind of view this this if you if you
imagine the plane is like one of those
those huge blades that magicians use to
solve people in half or pretend like
they're or give us the illusion of
sawing people in half it might look
something like this okay so you're like
okay I you know that's not so hard to
digest that I can if I intersect a plane
with a cube I can get a square I could
get a rectangle but what about triangles
well once again and pause the video if
you think you can figure it out
triangles not so bad you could cut this
side right over here this side this side
right over here and this side right over
here and then this is and of course I
could keep drawing the plane but I think
you get the idea this would be a
triangle there's different types of
triangles that you can construct you
could construct a you can construct an
equilateral triangle so as long as this
cut is the same length as this cut right
over here is the same length as hot
weird Enders or the length that it
intersects on this space of the cube
that's going to be an equilateral
triangle if you pushed this point out
more actually let me do that in a
different color if you push it out more
you're going to have an isosceles
triangle you're going to have an
isosceles triangle if you were to bring
this point really really really close
like here you would approach having a
right angle but it wouldn't be it
wouldn't be quite a right angle you'd
still have these angles would still be
less than 90 degrees you can approach 90
degrees so you can't quite have an
exactly a right angle and so you can't
get to 90 degrees you definitely not
going to get to 91 degree so you're
actually not going to be able to do an
obtuse triangle either but you can do an
equilateral you can do an isosceles you
can do scalene triangles I guess you
could say you could do the different
types of acute triangles but now let's
do some really interesting things can
you get a Pentagon by slicing a cube
with a plane and I really want you to
pause the video and think about it here
because that's just just a fun to think
think about how can you get
a pentagon by slicing a cube with a
plane alright so here I go this is how
you can get a Pentagon by slicing a cube
with the plane imagine slicing the top
let me do it a little bit different
so imagine slicing the top right over
there
so we imagine slicing the top like this
but imagine slicing this backside
imagine slicing this backside like that
this backside that you can't see quite
like that
now you slice this side right over here
like this like this and then you slice
this side right over here like this this
could be like if I wanted to draw on the
plane maybe it won't be so obvious if I
try to draw the plane but you get the
actual idea if I slice this the right
angle not at a right angle at the right
at a right angle actually I should you
zoom in with a right angle that'll
confuse everything if I slice it in the
proper angle that I am with the
intersection of my plane and my cube is
going to be is going to be this Pentagon
right over here
now let's up the stakes something let's
up the stakes even more what about a
hexagon can I slice a cube in a way with
a two-dimensional plane to get at the
intersection of the plane and the cube
being a hexagon well as you could
imagine I wouldn't have asked you the
question unless I could so let's see if
we can do it so if we slice this if we
slice this right over there if we slice
this bottom piece right over there and
then you slice this back side like that
you slice this backside like that and
then you slice this side that we can see
right over there and then this side that
we can see right over there to the side
I could have written it much straighter
so hopefully you get the idea I could I
can slice this cube so that I can
actually get a hexagon
so hopefully this this gives you a
better appreciation for what you can
actually do with a cube especially if
you're busy slicing it with a large
planer
Planes large planer blades in in some
way there's actually more to a cube than
maybe you might have imagined in the
past and one way to think about it is
there are six sides to a cube and so are
six surfaces to a cube so you can cut as
many as six of the surfaces when you
intersect it with a plane and every time
you cut into one of those surfaces it
forms a side so here we're cutting it to
four sides here we're cutting it to four
surfaces or four sides here we're
cutting into three here cutting into
five we're not cutting into the bottom
of the cube here and here we're cutting
into all six of the sides all six of the
surfaces of the faces of this cube